hi everyone its Charlie this is gonna be
my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 6
finale Q&A video just addressing
everything from the end of this season
so here we go
I'll be doing more videos for the Game
of Thrones prequel series starting in
the next week we have a bonus episode
for Game of Thrones happening tonight of
course I'll do a video for that so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
George R Martin was talking about winds
of winter recently so I'll try to add
some book stuff to my future bonus
videos too we'll do a new round of the
HBO now giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll also talk
about the other HBO shows that are
coming later like Watchmen at the end of
the video obviously careful for spoilers
for everything through Game of Thrones
season 8 here we go so first question
dibble g300 asks do you think there will
be multiple endings in the blu-ray
release I've rather they filmed multiple
endings I'm hoping that bands that are
loyal to one house get to see that house
win at the end so you're asking about
wildly different endings I think that
there were a couple different versions
of the ending that they filmed just to
mislead people in case leaks got out but
I don't think they're gonna be that
different when they say they filmed
different endings I think that that's
just extra scenes with a couple of side
characters and then a couple different
ways that Daenerys winds up dying
because that was all filmed on a closed
set green screen with just John Daenerys
and the people that were filming it
there are a lot of people that think
that there were multiple actors that
they had killed Daenerys just to make it
seem like anybody could be killing her
by the end of the season but I think it
was always part of her plan to die at
the end of the season to melt the Iron
Throne in for Jon Snow to go north so
I'm not expecting any crazy different
endings and as for different houses
winning you really only have House
Targaryen at the end through Daenerys
and kind of Jon Snow how stark in house
lannister and how stark did kind of seem
like it won the game of Thrones so to
speak because brands on the Iron Throne
sonses on the throne of the north but
you also have to remember that Tyrion
survived - and I don't think there's any
version of the ending where Tyrion winds
up on the Iron Throne and if they did
have multiple different actors killed
Daenerys I don't think they would put
that on the blu-ray but if they had a
couple extra scenes that they actually
polished off they might put those on
with the secondary characters we'll find
out more about
later this summer though next question
Marco asks I read about a deleted scene
for Daenerys as ending where she gets
resurrected like John in season six
thoughts so I don't know about this I
think there's been rumors floating
around but I don't know how true they
are if they really did do something like
this then I think it was one of those
fake scenes that they film like they did
during season seven with Jon Snow
Daenerys on the beach just hanging out
like there was a scene with them just
sitting around to mislead paparazzi so
they could have done a couple things
like that for the finale but I don't
think there's any version of this where
Daenerys winds up surviving next
question Homa Taha asks I want to know
how bran is a good thing I mean what did
George are Martin really think is he a
monarch who can intimidate the High
Lords and inspire the people a ruler
loved by millions with a powerful army
in the right family name well I think
that people love the Starks but you have
to remember that that line that Varys
cape to Tyrion at the beginning of
season 5 was completely the show's
creation that's not a george RR martin
line this is where we get to the idea
that not all the foreshadowing
completely makes sense because i think
the idea is is that if bran does wind up
winning the Iron Throne
ultimately in George RR Martin's version
of the ending he'll do a much better job
of seating that and foreshadowing with
clues whereas going into season 5
remember how they didn't have brand at
all during that season I don't think at
that point they knew that they were
going to put brand on the Iron Throne in
their version of the finale had they
have known that they probably would have
spent more time for shadowing it in
brands visions in the things that he was
doing with the three-eyed Raven the
lessons that he was teaching him while
he was in the process of becoming the
new three-eyed Raven so at the end of
the day I think it's just the show's
failure and deciding late in the game
that they were gonna put brain on the
Iron Throne even if that is gonna be
George RR Martin's ultimate ending we
don't know if George R Martin was gonna
put brain on the Iron Throne but he is a
very central character in Martin's story
so it's still wide open to speculation
there's more evidence to suggest that
Daenerys is gonna wind up being killed
by Jon Snow then there is to suggest
that bran will wind up on the Iron
Throne but I'll talk about this in my
other points too I do think that Jon
Snow will ultimately wind up living in
exile regardless of what the reason is
by the end of A Song of Ice and Fire
next question Matthew chord own asks
hopefully the prequel will be able to
make up for some of the finales
shortcomings I think for the most part
that the prequel series will help
what's going on with the children of the
force and the White Walkers in a much
much better way
the prequel series is mostly taking
place during the time of the first men
before the Andal invasion
so you're mostly dealing with a lot of
the heavy mythology that we only got
into later in the main series which as
we all saw they brushed over really
quickly so if you're really upset at the
way they dealt with the White Walkers
and the way they explained all that
stuff I feel like the prequel will fix a
lot of that and they won't be completely
beholden to everything that the main
show did they'll be able to take a few
more liberties because it's a completely
different creative team and just to be
clear Dan and Dave don't have anything
to do with any of the Game of Thrones
prequel series remember there's four
different ones
the long night blood moon one is the one
that they're filming right now there was
a little bit of confusion at that in the
last couple of weeks so hopefully that
just clarifies what's going on but
they're shooting the first prequel right
now
next question res tan asks why is there
a Night's Watch that's a good question I
think the idea on this show is they want
to keep that institution alive so they
have a place to send people that they
don't want to throw in prison there's a
lot of conjecture and theories about
what the real meaning of them sending
John to the Nights Watch was the White
Walkers are gone in the realm does not
hate the wildlings anymore so they're
not trying to keep them out of the south
so really they don't need the Nights
Watch for their previously stated
purpose so for now we just think of the
Nights Watch and everything north of the
wall is a glorified white collar prison
next question McDavid asks what's the
name of the tag song at the end the song
at the end where Jon Snow and the
wildlings are walking into the haunted
forest is called a Song of Ice and Fire
it's a little bit of the game of thrones
main theme song remixed with a choral
theme and a bit of the stark theme next
question dot Ryan asks still confused
about where all those various messages
went also John kil tenaris but he was
the rightful king why wouldn't he yeah
why wouldn't he kill the person that he
was totally in love with the idea about
Jon Snow killing Daenerys is that it was
a measure of last resort and he's
wounded to the core metaphorically
speaking for the rest of his life and
he's just gonna have to live through
that pain but also a lot of people
supported Daenerys right up to the end
she had all those forces so even though
they didn't do a great job of it they
wanted to explain that it would have
plunged the kingdom into another Civil
War which is why you have all those
council scenes obviously they needed a
lot more to fill in those story gaps
because
too many people were confused about why
characters made some of those decisions
but I think the idea with the various
messages of him trying to inform all the
Lords of the realm about jon snow's
parentage that he did not get to send
most of those because it looked like he
was writing them as he was going so
maybe a couple of them got out but I
think the idea was is that it didn't
work the way he wanted it to he didn't
gain the support that he was hoping that
it would garner next question Joelle
Coutinho asks what do you think about
one of the theories going around of Jon
being killed by drogon maybe that would
have been a better ending well I think
the idea is they wanted a bittersweet
tragic ending and it's sweet that they
won the Iron Throne but bitter that Jon
Snow was forced to kill the person that
he loves at the end look at his face
here - he definitely thought that drogon
was gonna kill him he was already to die
that probably would have spared him the
pain of having to live with what he'd
done so that would have been a mercy and
I don't think they wanted to give that
to him
next question reg 100 and first asks
next topic does the realm know of Jon's
lineage and him being the rightful heir
to the Iron Throne
would that overwrite his sentence to the
Nights Watch this is one of those things
where it's not totally clear what was
going on in that battle scene they
didn't do a good job of explaining who
knows and who doesn't know about Jon's
lineage I think it's safe to assume that
a couple of them probably knew about
Jon's lineage but because they voted
brand to be king of their new realm and
they're going forward the system every
new king after brand is going to be
picked by great council so it really
won't matter what your bloodline is or
if you're the rightful heir so it's just
a failure of the script missing scenes
call it whatever you want that they
didn't explain that maybe some people
knew and they didn't care or they'd
already been talking about it and they
moved past it next question rpm asks
who's going to execute John if he
father's children with a wildling his
brother or sister well I think the idea
about that is is that nobody's going to
be checking on him even though Sansa
would probably every once in a while
every couple of years just because he's
north of the wall doesn't mean that
he'll never see anybody from the realm
again remember all they have to do is
just open the gate and walk north of the
wall so if salsa wanted to go visit her
brother Jon Snow to see that he was
alright and find out what he'd been
doing for the last say ten years
nobody's gonna stop her at Castle black
you can write whatever fanfiction you
want about John Snow having mountains
and mountains of wildling children with
some wildling woman that he winds up
falling in love with in ten or twenty
years if he ever actually did break his
vows get married and have children I
don't think that Sansa would tell on him
even though she seems pretty hardcore at
this point of the story
next question father Joe asks what about
cold hands so I'm not sure if you're
asking about Benjen cold hands from the
TV show or the book version of cold
hands who's a different character if
you're asking about benjin he was killed
by the night king during episode six
when he helped Jon Snow escape by giving
him his horse that was him sort of
sacrificing himself for a final time but
if you're asking about book cold hands
it's implied that it's actually a
completely different character who's
much more ancient than Benjen stark and
we'll find out about them during winds
of winter but it's still a big mystery
as to who cold hands really is I'm
assuming for now that it's the same
logic of benjin and that he's sort of a
half-turn person that the children saved
from becoming a white but he'll wind up
being some other ancient king of men
like I used to live south of the realm
thousands of years ago but then the
children of the forest saved me and ever
since then I've been ranging the north
helping the children of the forest and
the three-eyed Ravens that have come
along next question Sariah Medina asks
is this the end of House Targaryen
pretty much they're trying to say that
Daenerys is dead and then Jon Snow is
probably not going to father more
children so effectively it's the end of
House Targaryen
you could say that if there's some
Targaryen bastards out there that is
always possible the Targaryen blood
survives because Gendry as a Baratheon
does have a little bit of Targaryen
blood in him through Robert Baratheon's
grandmother so remember that house
Baratheon actually started from Oris
Baratheon who was one of the bastards of
Aegon the conquerors father
so Oris Baratheon was sort of the Jon
Snow of Aegon Targaryen family way back
before the conquest next question Haroon
asks how do you think the Game of
Thrones should have ended this is the
fanfic question of the day everybody has
their own better version of the finale
maybe I'll do a separate video about
this it's a little bit longer because
you do have to get really technical
because if you change a couple things
early on then it changes things for
other characters later on so we just
spirals outward and outward and bigger
and bigger changes as you go on but
starting in season six I was a Jon
Snow's storyline is still the same
Melisandre brings him back to life he
leaves the Nights Watch forms a new
northern alliance to get rid of Ramsay
Bolton
reclaims Winterfell for the Starks at
the end of the season is named king of
the north
when Daenerys comes to Westeros in
season seven she's already lost one of
her dragons Vissarion in enough of her
unsullied in Dothraki iran has obtained
dragon bind her instead of doing the
scorpion thing maybe they do scorpions
later too but he also has dragon bind
her so that it seems more like even odds
of Cersei versus Daenerys their forces
seem more evenly matched but by the end
of season 7 Jon Snow convinces Daenerys
of the threat of the White Walkers by
just taking her on a dragon ride on
drogon north of the wall they're almost
killed they barely escaped with Drogo in
their lives so she joins him by the end
of that season in season eight is an
entire season of the long night in them
fighting the White Walkers we get a full
10 seasons all 10 episodes per season so
that you can flesh out the side
characters storylines - during season 8
the night king fly south to King's
Landing and starts turning the citizens
forcing Cersei to join their alliance
and defeat the night King Jon Snow
learns the truth about his heritage so
he gets a chance to ride regal they pay
that off Jon Snow Targaryen riding the
dragon named after his father but
Daenerys winds up losing Rago by the end
of the season along with sir Jorah
causing her to become more isolated more
paranoid self-destructive in her desire
to kill the night king so the season 8
cliffhanger is them killing the night
king pushing them into season 9 season 9
is where the alliance with Cersei
crumbles and they start the final battle
for the Iron Throne Jon Snow and
Daenerys decide to get married in the
finale at the very end of the season
after Jon learns that she's pregnant
with their child it's a happy WTF moment
because they spent all this time
foreshadowing a pregnancy and Daenerys
thought that she'd never have another
child and she's already lost so much but
Daenerys has hate for the night King in
the White Walkers in killing those close
to her spills over completely into
Cersei she becomes way more vicious and
it starts to disturb the people around
her a little bit but she's a long ways
away from being called anything like the
Mad Queen she just talks about burning
people more and more frequently
season 10 begins with the wedding of Jon
Snow in Daenerys this is the final
season john tells her the truth about
who he is at the beginning of the season
before the wedding complicating things
the other lords learn about it but they
just assume that they're getting married
so the rule Westeros as king and queen
and there won't be any problems but
they're still trying to get Searcy out
of King's Landing
Euron uses dragon binder to almost
killed Rogan Daenerys has pushed over
the edge
she hates Cersei more than she hated the
night King at this point it just talks
about burning King's Landing on the
regular people think that she's joking
she's not joking then mid season big WTF
moment Daenerys winds up miscarrying
during one of the battles after she's
knocked off of drogon midair then the
back half of the season those final four
episodes is her grief slowly consuming
her to the point at which she really
does actually want to burn the people of
King's Landing in her desire to get rid
of Cersei and all those that serve her
half of the realm starts to have
misgivings about putting Daenerys on the
Iron Throne and keeping her in power in
favor of Jon Snow being the sole person
to be making all these decisions but
because Daenerys is such a strong
personality they're worried that Jon
Snow will be able to manage her causing
more and more tension within their
alliance Jon Snow's still deeply in love
with Daenerys doesn't know what to do
about her because she seems to be going
matter in matter just like the Mad King
slowly descended into his madness he was
actually a pretty good King when he
started out as a young man by the end of
the season he finally realizes that he's
forced to kill her there's no other
choice and in his intense grief decides
to exile himself to the far north to
live out the rest of his days is a
wildling with ghosts so he chooses to go
to the north it's not them forcing him
to take the black that's probably enough
fanfiction for now I'm sure there's
gonna be a whole bunch of this on tumblr
but if you guys have an alternate
version of the ending that you would
have liked better let me know what that
was in the comments recent comments from
george RR martin implied that he was
going to have winds of winter out by
2020 or sometime during 2020 so if it's
not out by the end of this year which I
don't think that it will be then it
probably sometime next year when we're
into the prequel series so I will be
doing Game of Thrones prequel TV series
episode videos just like I did for the
main series but when we start to get
book stuff I'll do Game of Thrones Song
of Ice and Fire book videos - if you
have any specific requests for book
stuff just let me know in the comments
below there is that bonus episode of
Game of Thrones that's happening tonight
I'll do a video for that but that might
not post till Monday morning just
because it's like two hours long and
it's not gonna start till 9:00 p.m. so
it's gonna be
super late by the time I finished that
video so as long as you have alerts
enabled you'll see it when I post it no
worries congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big Game of Thrones
video
NOLA Nolan please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here for my video
for the ending of Game of Thrones and
click here for my Game of Thrones season
8 episode 6 finale Easter eggs video
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight